I'm black-ish of course your character  wears a Halloween costume yeah and this  tell me who this is because this is  pretty it's it's a character called  that's you yes you are right then and  this is a character what's his name this  name is shown up shown up  yes I don't know if you young kids ahead  know who's showing up is but showing up  was a pivotal character growing up in  our community to everybody white black  Hispanic everybody showing up was the  man well weren't sure enough come from  this movie called last dragon up again  you look good as show enough you have  seen oh you you're in shape you look in  rage you look as and rage this show  enough  I am so enough yeah look just everybody  told me on one Halloween they saw that  you want it didn't know it was a contest  but I want